one of the best things about chemistry
for me is the color changes and how you
can actually get several color changes
from one solution and what looks like in
here just to me it's apple juice to
Brady a little iron brew but it does
really look like a soft drink so if we
pour it into these glasses we could
actually see whether any change happens
once you pour them in so I'm going to
pour it in like so
so that we've got some red wine there
mmm banana milk let's try some
I'm not sure possibly whiskey of some
sort okay that just looks like ink cuts
gross
that's like some kind of energy drink
and finally inside here it looks more
like tea so yeah there's a little bit of
the original solution in there so we
started out in here with ammonium iron
sulfate and inside these glasses
actually several different chemicals and
what these color changers represent are
the different exchanges of ions that
took place so what do I mean by that the
best thing is actually show you what's
inside these glasses so this red wine
that is in glass number one is actually
it was spiked with potassium thiocyanate
so right down here where lil bit
potassium thiocyanate and when I added
the ammonium iron sulfate it's actually
the thiocyanate ions that are binding
with the iron to give you this molecule
here this complex and glass number two
actually had barium chloride in it and
it's the barium that's reacting this
time to give you that back color and now
we've got a completely different color
here with glass number three and
actually what's reacting in this case is
something called potassium ferrocyanide
so here it's the ferrocyanide this time
that's reacting with the iron and giving
you that color there here what looks
like some kind of inky substance is
actually the result of the reaction with
tannic acid so the tannic acid is the
one that's forming the complex here and
then the complete change we've got
something here that's less cloudy a lot
more clear looks bright yellow yeah
which yeah we all know what that looks
like but it's nothing to do with your
ear it's actually tartaric acid that's
reacted to give us that and last but not
least this one which is going back to
where it was didn't like tea it's now
looking more like I dunno brandy it's
actually sodium bisulfite so sodium
hydrogen sulfite is inside that glass
and that is six colors from that one
solution
inside the balloon is then accelerated
by the breaking balloon you can see it's
being accelerated hard down towards the
rest of the water and causing these
fantastic ripples these waves on the
surface and then this is continuing out
down so there's the water that we've
accelerated at the top from the balloon
bursting this way is now accelerating
out towards the bottom